and then I I had heard one time somebody
say that like um your body's kind of
like a a blank canvas or a journal and
every single one of your tattoos is like
a journal entry did gay guys tell you
that
[Music]
all right this um this news is
interesting because it feels more like
this is America but actually this news
is China oh dude one in the same this
teenager gets a tattoo right yeah it
costs 115 bucks oh this one
115 bucks yep cost 150 bucks she gets a
tattoo 115 what's their currency in
China
you won you won so that's like 800 yuan
that's the cost of an expensive haircut
yeah oh for a tattoo so gods of an
expensive anything you you guys got a
hundred dollar haircut I don't get 100
haircuts but I know some people that do
haul as much as yours Tim
my
I saved so much more money than you
because I haven't got a haircut since
[__] lockdown and you look great
thank you
so do you but you've spent money on it I
know
I have to because your hair used to be
loud what happened you got an image
something no but I'm trying to look
young and pero also your skit had a fade
though the thing about it is now when my
sides aren't fresh when the fade isn't
fresh you see these Grays trickling oh
mine's like that too
yeah so I need to keep my [__] fresh
nice diet no I like to eat
I love that [__] I [__] love that
[__] you got a good crap for that I
almost got my skateboard and hit
everybody with this
what you're wearing the same sweater as
yesterday chill out man hey hey I had to
represent my unrelated burn well that's
what he'd be doing you ain't shouting
the wheat dog shut the [__] up
hey I gotta do shorts though these are
Adidas those are cool unrelated another
thing but shorts good shorts and the
under the t-shirt's new okay
what brand Reebok it's a Spartan oh from
the Spartan Race when'd you do the
Spartan Race
four years ago it's a nice shirt baby
how was it it's a participation award
love the merch yep okay tell us about
all right so this tattoo right Chinese
teen gets a tattoo spends about 115
bucks decides that he doesn't want it
and regrets it oh so he sues the tattoo
artist who gave it to him
they sue over there that is American
holy [__] so young
that's why uh people
they have the bystander effect in China
because like remember we found out that
people don't help each other because
they'll be like oh if this guy's injured
and I help him out they can turn around
and sue me uh interesting yeah
they um so he Sues and he Demands a
refund an apology and approximately
three thousand dollars whoa you can't be
suing for more than what you pay
[__] but here's what happened
he ended up winning what and the court
ordered the tattoo artist to pay him 717
bucks
so seven times basically seven times
what he paid what's his tattoo look like
it looks like a you look good it looks
like a sleeve I'll show you right now
you got to sleep for 150 bucks which is
really surprising you know but I read
this article too look at that and he got
the whole thing for 15 bucks let's go to
China dude a part of the reason that he
won is because he's so young and it was
like
that's the uh that's the key right there
he was underage you're not allowed to
even sell somebody a tattoo when they're
under 18. with false pretense you're not
cool if you card I got an underage
tattoo this is this is exactly why you
can't sell to people underage because
they don't [__] know what they're
doing they're stupid yeah I have it
under it too which one throwing on my
chest that's an underage I got that [__]
at 16. how are you I got 16. but that
means that tattoo place is cool
how did you get it without your parents
like writing a note and [__]
me and my friend we started hanging out
asking visiting and then after like
three months of convincing he was like
all right I'll give you two a tattoo
what's it say because I was like I want
to learn how to tattoo so he goes come
in and draw
and then it's just it's a call it's my
last oh word yeah my buddy has one too
we got at the same time but he was like
a year or no he was all he was almost
18. he got you to college oh 16. wait
you got juicycala no
[Laughter]
he got his Japanese name on both chests
on both both sides and I got mine right
here and then um yeah we should just
hang out there all the time and we're
just like come on man he goes nah I
can't do it man you're not you just get
bugging the [__] and I was like hey but
check it out though I want to be a
tourist one day and then he goes all
right well well we can't let you tattoo
but I mean if you want to hang around
and just draw I teach you so then I
would just we would just be there all
the time just drawing and drawing and
showing our dedication and after three
months he's all like
all right come here and he just tattooed
us and then after that
dude a lot of dedication I want to
understand
I want to show my grand
it's a cool apprenticeship I didn't know
we were just we were just about to learn
and do all this stuff and then one day
he's all like hey I heard you're selling
drugs and I was like well how else am I
gonna pay for tattoos and stuff and
you're like [__] he's like nah man he
goes you either become a tattoo artist
or and you quit that [__] or what's up
and I was like
I would stay a drug dealer so I see you
didn't become a tattoo artist good old
Gardena
I got my first tattoo like a month ago
really what is that oh
the champ stand okay it's a bit it's
like a male [__] stamp really it's um
it's it's chocolate
um in Thai in my dad's handwriters
how did your dad feel about you getting
a tattoo so let me tell you my dad was
like so against tattoos for so long and
that's a big reason why I didn't get any
right and then one day he was just like
you know what yeah yeah whatever I was
oh [__] and he was like you know what if
you let me draw it then then I'll be
cool with it right and then I told him I
wanted to get John the wrong so he was
like let me do it in my hand right I was
like oh lit so he sent me a few options
and then um it's just on like right
right under my neck right there oh
that's so cool bro I thought you
actually had a [__] stamp and you're
gonna turn around and show us a [__]
no no no no he's just gonna go like this
yeah you can still see that from the
back yeah
first tattoo that's tight are you gonna
get more I'm thinking about it because I
watched so much ink master like oh do
you yeah so I like follow the different
artists on Instagram and [__] and here's
what I want to do is like you know so my
daughter's name is Veda right and people
always say Darth Vader like Rick Rick
calls her Dorothy and [__] you know so I
wanted to get a new school tattoo with
veda's face as Darth Vader
um doing some like you know like I don't
know like like [__] choking a teddy
bear or something and there's one artist
specifically that does a lot of like new
school and she does portraits and I like
follow she's in Massachusetts but I'm
like oh man that would be sick if I get
this like on my thigh or some [__] you
know so I'm like thinking about it I
don't know hell yeah you know this is
cool so that's who's a [__] sick and
especially if your dog girl's gonna be
like yeah I'm choking a [__] on a
[__] tattoo that's cooler than you
know some some cute stuff sometimes and
then JK news across my chest yeah whoa
and Kirkland on your lower back yeah
that's crazy and fun Bros right here
yeah yeah
that's crazy you avoided getting tattoos
for so long growing up in Paramount I
feel like that [__] would have been mad
easy to get I what yes your [__]
prison tattoos I mean you know I avoided
it for a long time okay when I was
younger I wanted like so many tattoos
right [__] I had a whole list of [__]
me too yeah yeah
when I got older I was like
and I know I want to do the acting [__]
and I wanted to just keep everything
looking pure especially since like I
feel like as an Asian actor I can play
really young for a long time right so in
my head it was gonna come down to me and
the guy without tattoos and I'm like oh
we gotta cover his [__] up let's go with
this guy and also my dad was super
against it
and then I just kind of got to a point
where I went so long without tattoos I
felt kind of special you know I'm like
oh everybody has a tooth I'm one of the
only people without tattoos you're pure
blood a pure skin sexy boy right but
then I was like all right I'm grown
let's [__] do it that's cool that's
it that's cool man did any of you guys
get tattoos underage did you get one
before you were 18. no
what about your fear everyone when was
that 19 so right after yeah you got that
too I just have
um find it find it
I just had this this one hold on take it
all off dude excuse me you have a lot of
layers bro it's cold in here why
oh that's clean it was like um it's like
a bandana pattern mixed with like tribal
so it's sort of like Filipino Americans
is it unfinished it is unfinished that's
what I thought yeah she uh the artist
died for real no
oh my God
[Laughter]
because also sometimes I feel like I'm
too old for pain you know what I mean
you're too old for pain yeah like so I'm
I'm getting a tattoo next month
because I have to uh are they gonna
knock you out first no I told them I was
like yo I'm like you guys got the
numbing creams and [__] I'm too old for
[__] pain man
I have a friend that goes to um
well he has a full body suit right and
what he does is he goes to the laser
tattoo removal place yeah because they
can do these injections which is way
stronger than a cream so he goes there
inject it up and then he goes to the
tattoo part it just stays on that's
cheating but he gets his whole body then
he goes I don't feel [__] for real but
he's not for me I'm like it sounds like
the move that sounds kind of cool
because I'm too old for pain man yeah a
lot of people put a topical anal cream
what yeah you know yeah there's a
tropical anal cream is that for like
butt sex but Young
yeah sometimes people need that [__] oh
it's a hemorrhoid cream yeah that makes
sense but it's like really numbing off
of a topical thing so if you wipe that
and then you don't feel it but the only
thing is that what you did say is you do
it it makes you want to have anal sex
the only thing is if you're doing like a
longer piece when the thing wears out
you feel the pain everywhere at once
I'd rather do that I don't mind feeling
the pain everywhere I want I just want
to be sitting through like five hours of
pain what was your longest session for a
tattoo they're all like seven eight
hours oh one like one straight through
yeah like this bottom one because
there's so much little detail yeah it
was like
um looks good though it was like four
eight hour sessions damn and it's a long
four eight thirty two hours hey that's
really long for that that area just down
here just for myself because sometimes
I'll be like this for [__] like four
you gotta use a small needle huh yeah
they're gonna be like that's really long
for that like stupid looking texture
yeah remember that white cat
you said it I don't sound like man
that's like a too old to be looking to
sit around [__] crying and [__] you
know I didn't you already know this
one's gonna hurt more than any other
part in your arm that's why I need my
creams get the [__] out of here dude so
Nick when you get a tattoo you don't
have one right are you gonna get just a
black belt tattooed right now dude no
because I'll be a brown belt forever I'm
a white belt forever hey straight up
dude I think you should get more great
tattooed on you man the way the way it's
written in the [__] cupboard Mark
great get your mom's name yeah you don't
want no tattoos your whole life huh I
don't think I'm not like like not down
to get one what if you get like a
regular ear right here
then it'll that'll hurt my feelings
actually even the mention of it will
hurt his feelings don't talk about
normal ears around me okay all right
fine or a black belt I'm sick of it you
never thought about getting one and then
you were like nah you know yeah it's
never been a thing I never really had
anything in my mind that I was like oh I
makes me really want to get that for
some reason I don't know why maybe later
maybe if I like I think having a kid
down the line
yeah yeah that's true yeah I always hear
the people like yo first one has to be
so meaningful and after that they're
like yeah [__] tattoo the Nestle
Crunch bar
oh that's good okay I'll do that and
they're walking in the shop pointing at
the wall I'll take two of those yeah
that's a cool bird
because that's what they say though
right like once you get one you're like
oh I'm hooked for sure the mentality
that changed Mama because I also was
like man I gotta get like the right
Dance Gotta Be meaningful and dope right
and then I I had heard one time somebody
say that like um your body's kind of
like a a blank canvas or a journal and
every single one of your tattoos is like
a journal entry oh yeah I smell like a
journal yeah that's cooler because
because like then I could get something
stupid or dumb they're gay guys tell you
that
and the artist gets better and better
like no matter who the best person you
find out in five years that person sucks
ass yeah
that's true that's why I don't get no
tattoos there it just keeps getting
better
what I liked before [__] hate it now
I know dude there's so many I'm glad I
didn't get yeah that's another reason
I'm a very wishing woman yes I almost
got Old English [__] letters on my
back saying what [__] it yo mama you say
say what you say yeah just nisei that
means second generation
it's stupid
why do people even know I'm a second
generation Japanese why it's the old
English thing in Old English that's
what's good about like tattoos being
hard to get is that if they weren't we
would have been [__] had Integra Type
R on our lower back
we would all have that right not me I
would have had 94 Toyota Corolla
[Music]
foreign